hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast sensitive and specific
multiplex real-time pcr assays for
assessing the abundance of extremely
rare mutations associated with cancer
diagnosis prognosis and therapy i'm
kristina jewel of lab rose and i'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning before we
begin just a couple of important
announcements this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A Zoe left I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Fred Kramer Fred Russell
Cramer is professor of microbiology
biochemistry and molecular genetics at
the New Jersey Medical School at Rutgers
University and has been a principal
investigator at the Public Health
Research Institute for the past 30 years
he graduated from the University of
Michigan in 1964 and received his
doctorate from the Rockefeller
University in 1969 he was on the faculty
of the department of genetics and
development at Columbia University
College of Physicians and Surgeons for
17 years and was a research professor an
adjunct professor in the department of
microbiology at new york university
school of medicine for 27 years I will
now hand over to dr. Kramer for his
presentation dr. Kramer
okay I hope you all can hear me uh let
me put on my slides Oh make sure okay
very good okay what I'm going to talk
about today is the work of four members
of our laboratory shown on the screen
Salvatore Maris Deanna Vargas Sanjay
yagi and myself and basically what I'm
going to be speaking about is a way to
do liquid biopsies for cancer now what
do I mean by a liquid biopsy imagine if
you go into a doctor's office for your
annual checkup and in addition to taking
a blood sample to check for your
cholesterol or whatever they take a
blood sample a small blood sample say 10
ml and they use that blood sample to
look for somatic fragments of DNA in the
blood in the blood plasma which contains
somatic mutations indicative of the
presence of cancer anywhere's in your
body this is quite possible it's known
now that cancer cells rapidly divide and
also rapidly die from apoptosis and
necrosis and as a result those cells are
chopped up by enzymes and fragments of
the genome of the cells that have died
end up in your bloodstream for a short
period of time wouldn't it be wonderful
if taking a blood sample and a regular
checkup could detect extremely rare
somatic mutations indicative of cancer
long before there's any symptoms and it
would comfort anywhere's in your body
but by identifying which mutations you
have you'd be able to early on treat
before there are symptoms and hopefully
the idea is if the assays are sensitive
enough to detect these very rare DNA
fragments that you can
successfully treat a person which might
be much more difficult if you waited
until symptoms occur I'll give you other
examples of the advantage of having a
very simple blood test for cancer if
you've been treated for cancer if you
have had a tumor removed or a bone
marrow transplant right now they're
still a worry that you have cancer cells
in your body it's the problem of minimal
residual disease therefore people are
automatically given very toxic drugs to
treat to treat the potential that cancer
could return wouldn't it be much better
if there was simple blood test so
sensitive that it could detect the
presence of those remaining cancer cells
and not only that because the clinical
studies done with that test you could
determine at what levels it's not
necessary to add any drugs and you could
follow that patients over time
periodically testing the patient and
only if the level of cancer cells goes
above a predetermined amount would you
then treat treat the cancer with a toxic
drug another example is if you're being
treated with a drug you know that cancer
cells can develop mutations which
generate resistance to that truck right
now you often have to wait until you
have symptoms that's not good wouldn't
it be better if patient could be
followed regularly and those mutations
detected long before there are any
symptoms so that the drugs administered
to that patient could be changed that's
personalized medicine one last example
some people inherit mutations which
aren't cancer per se but which are
defects in repairing mutations that
occur these are the BRCA mutations they
often can allow mutations to occur that
lead to cancer breast cancer ovarian
cancer and uh if you wait until symptoms
come from these it's often too late and
you die so many women have prophylactic
breast removal or ovaries removed
wouldn't it be much better if there was
a test so sensitive that periodically
these women could be tested for the
occurrence of cancer and early on if
it's detected do something about it cure
it and therefore there wouldn't be
necessary to have prophylactic breast
removal or ovaries removed so that whole
talk is about how you could take a
simple blood test or plasma from from a
blood sample and tested for the presence
of rare mutations and the single biggest
problem that has to be overcome is that
almost all the DNA fragments in your
blood in your plasma come from normal
cells and the only difference between
those fragments from normal cells and
fragments from the cancer cell is often
just a single nucleotide substitution a
single nucleotide polymorphism so how
can you do a simple low-cost test that
can be administered frequently and yet
selectively analyze that sample for
those rare somatic mutations and so the
tests that we've been working on is a
blue race chain reaction a PCR test and
first let me show you the problem in the
first slide uh here are two pcr
reactions that we ran each initiated
with a million uh DNA fragments but one
was with wild-type fragments and the
other was with mutant mutants fragments
and you'll you can see that using a
primer which is diagrammed in the upper
left hand corner where one nucleotide in
the middle as the open circle is
complementary to the mutation but not
complementary to the wild-type makes no
difference they the primers bind equally
well and and you can't distinguish the
wild type from the mutant what I'm going
to talking about today is we've invented
a new type of primer a primer which is
functions are broken into two parts I'm
going to try and use a little pointer
here sort of over here on the five prime
side of the primer you see I'm indicate
little red line is something that looks
very much like ordinary pcr primer and
it allows that primer to selectively to
bind only to the fragments of interest
to ignore all DNA fragments in in the
plasma that are not related to the gene
of interest and then on the other side
of this primer is a very short a segment
which is complementary to the region
that either will contain or not contain
the mutation and because this is short
it then we'll make a difference between
whether that that foot that little three
prime end there is able to bind to the
target or not if it matches the mutants
completely even though it might be only
seven nucleotides long it's going to
rapidly initiate the synthesis of a
product whereas if there's a mismatch
between that interrogating nucleotide
shown by the open circle and target
sequence that is if it's a wild-type
target sequence you can see it is almost
a twenty a cycle delay before any
product is made so this type of primer
where it's been broken into two
functional regions a five-prime region
that selectively binds the primer only
to the target of interest and then a
short a 3 prime region that because it's
short is able to bind only to the mutant
that you want to detect and joining the
two regions is something we call a
bridge and it's unrelated to the to the
sequence that you're trying to detect it
it's just quite separate but what we've
done here is we've we've allowed
ourselves to get a very small primer the
foot foot primer to make the distinction
had we use just a small primer by itself
it would have bound to 10,000 different
genes and wouldn't have done the trick
okay
here is the principal of these acids
sort of illustrated on the left you see
one of these we call them super
selective primers and if it match if the
interrogating nucleotide which is a G in
this case matches the mutant nucleotide
OC the foot sequence will bind and that
can initiate the synthesis of amplicons
whereas on the right side if there's a
mismatch the foot does not bind and it's
very unlikely to initiate the synthesis
of products here's a closer look at what
the super selective primer looks like
the primers on the top and the DNA
fragment that you want to detect is on
the bottom and you see the red
nucleotides is the anchor sequence that
serves the function at the 60 degree in
kneeling temperature of bringing the
primer to the targets of interest and
then on the right side the green
nucleotides show the foot sequence
containing the interrogating nucleotide
which if it's perfectly complementary to
the foot target containing the mutant
characteristic of cancer a amplicon will
begin to be made synthesis will occur
and you'll notice that the blue
nucleotides of the primer the bridge
sequence is not complementary to an
intervening sequence in the target that
separates the anchor target from the
foot target and there's a little code in
the lower left there this is a primer
that selectively amplifies a cancer
mutation b-raf v600e and you'll see the
code 24 14 / 14 5 11 that means the
anchor is twenty four nucleotides long
the bridge sequences 14 nucleotides long
the intervening sequence is also 14
nucleotides long and the interrogating
nucleotide is at the next to the last
position of the seven nucleotide long
foot that's why it's called 500
a closer look and there's that same
primer for brf v600e and at the bottom
you can see the pcr conditions are
absolutely normal ordinary the only
difference here is we substituted a
super selective primer for the usual
forward primer and as a regular
conventional reverse primer and
conditions are perfectly perfectly
normal one of the special and most
wonderful things about this approach to
selectively PCR is that the selection
only occurs when the super selective
primer binds to aid a minus targets read
we arbitrarily call it- and the foot
binds and gets extended so that upper
the upper diagram shows the super
selective primer being extended because
the foot matches the foot target however
in the next thermal cycle of the PCR the
conventional reverse primer copies the
whole amplicon generated in the top in
the top diagram making a copy a complete
copy of the entire super selective
primer sequence that is the bridge
sequence is now copied and a complement
to the bridge sequence ends up in the
new minus strand that's made so that in
the bottom diagram in the third cycle
that minus strand now serves as a quite
ordinary template for the super
selective primer and the super selective
primer acts as an ordinary primer so the
moment a selection event occurs on a DNA
fragment that's in the original sample
then the PCR is efficient and normal and
that's a beautiful thing so that's what
it is that selection is only an H cycle
on any initial DNA fragments that are
present here's a result of using a super
selective primer and I think this is a
key slider so we're looking here for
this b-raf mutation v600
and there are eight different samples
that were run if there's no DNA present
at all the red line shows you that
nothing is made if we started a reaction
with 1 million wild-type templates
that's the green line you see you do get
amplicons made but they don't appear
until about the 50th thermal cycle there
the initiation on that million wild
types is incredibly low probability and
the the blue reactions all contain a
million wild types but different numbers
of mutants and you see that depending on
how many mutants are present in the
sample that determines when there are
enough amplicons to see and the fewer
initial mutant templates that are
present the later those amplicons arise
but yet even 10 mutant molecules in the
presence of a million wild types occurs
earlier in the reaction than pure wild
types the machines you can use any PCR
machine to do these reactions in this
particular case we're using cyber green
to light up the amplicons the
instruments automatically that's that
dotted line determinate a level in which
synthesis has risen above background and
when when a thermal sight when when the
reaction has achieved a thermal cycle at
which there is a product amplicons above
background that's noted by the
instruments and can be plotted in the
following manner there is a relationship
between the threshold cycle where the
amplicon products above background occur
that's inversely linearly proportional
to the logarithm of the number of target
molecules present originally in the
sample so you see you get this beautiful
straight line and this relationship
between threshold cycle inverse
relationship between threshold cycle and
logarithm number of
targets which introduced by our
laboratory in 1989 in articles in nature
and in clinical chemistry and it's the
basis of real-time quantitative PCR
assays one more thing to plot here is
what is the what is the thermal the
threshold cycle of the pure wild type
and here it is plotted as a dotted green
line you see that 10 the 10 molecules of
target even in the presence of million
while types can be distinguished from a
million molecules of wild-type that's
how sensitive and selective are super
selective primers however nothing works
perfectly when we repeat this experiment
but this time we use a different
mutation as a target the egfr l 858 are
mutation now what distinguishes this
mutation from the beer athenee 600e the
brf v600e mutation occurred in an 80
rich region whereas the EGFR l 858
mutation occurs in a GC rich region and
you see when you do exactly the same
experiment as what was done with the
beer f now that 10 target molecules
can't really be well distinguished from
the from the pure wild-type alone and so
it's clear that the nature of the target
the strength of the foot hybrid that's
form is going to affect the selectivity
and so we looked into this in more
detail ah for instance if we lengthen
the foot sequence things get even worse
you see now there's really no difference
between a hundred target molecules in
the presence of a million wild types on
the other hand if we shorten that foot
sequence making a less strong foot
hybrid then you return to that full
linearity so making that the strength of
the hybrid that's form is going to
affect the selectivity that's our first
discovery
uh not only that we also looked at the
position in the foot of the
interrogating nucleotide and we just
compared reactions with a million while
types two reactions with a million
mutants and what you can see is having
the interrogating nucleotide at the
three prime end or at the next to the
three prime end where we assume that if
the penultimate base pair doesn't form
at 60 degrees the terminal base pair
will also knock form you you get good
discrimination but as you move that
interrogating nucleotide away from the
three prime end of the primer
discrimination is not as good we also
investigated the size of the bubble
formed by the bridge sequence and the
intervening sequence so here are
experiments done with a different
bubbles of different circumference 20
nucleotide bubble at 28 nucleotide
bubble and 30 36 nucleotide level and
again the bigger the bubble the better
of the discrimination and what does this
mean again I want to emphasize the
bigger the bubble when the foot these
little foot hybrids fall apart you'd
like them to go back together again and
there's an entropy factor the bigger the
bubble the less likely it is that the
foot and the foot target will come
together so in effect you have weakened
the free energy of formation of that
foot a hybrid but that leads to better
discrimination or okay one other thing
we looked into in the bubble is what if
it's not a symmetrical bubble what if
the bridge sequence is bigger than the
intervening sequence or vice versa and
basically I won't dwell on this it
doesn't matter all that matters is the
size of the bubble but the symmetry of
the bubble can be altered and that's
going to be very helpful in the design
of experiments that I'll be describing
okay Mike but taking this egfr l85 8r
mutation which didn't give the best of
results because it was a gc-rich target
we now repeated that experiment using a
shorter foot and a non-symmetric
slightly larger bubble made a bigger
bridge and then you see the results are
beautiful then you're able to
discriminate even 10 mutant molecules in
the presence of 1 million wild-type DNA
templates so we're going to come back to
this but a key factor in designing this
new way of doing extremely selective
extremely sensitive pcrs is that you
have to take into account the strength
of the foot hybrid that forms it's going
to affect the outcome and we'll get that
now we did these experiments with
linearized plasmids the ones that I
showed you so far in in this way it sort
of mimicked what you would find in a
liquid biopsy sample but they only had a
small segment of the gene of interest
the question is what happens if you use
all genomic DNA and we can get genomic
DNA from cell lines and we had for the
egfr l85 8r mutation we had a cell line
containing that mutation and another
cell line that was wild type and for
this a liquid biopsy is likely to have
DNA from something like 10,000 cells so
we used 10 DNA from 10,000 wild-type
cells and on the right side the result
is what you got with that green reaction
but if you mixed in with 10,000
wild-type DNA from 10,000 wild-type
cells the DNA from 10,000 mutant cells
and by the way these were fragmented
with restriction enzyme you got a
beautiful result it doesn't matter if
it's the whole human genome that's in
the sample
because the anchor sequence of the super
selective primers assures that the only
fragments that are paid attention to are
those that are complementary to that
anchor sequence one other thing we
wanted to see if the threshold cycle is
really reflecting the number of DNA
fragments that there are in the sample
so working with a company in in Portland
called molecular md uh they used DNA
from cell lines uh too and they
intermixed DNA from egfr a cell line
containing the EGFR mutation t790m with
about a wild-type DNA from about 13,000
wild-type cells and they ran a digital
PCR assay to count in a set volume the
amount of the number of molecules of
targets that were in there and they they
sent those samples to us but didn't tell
us how much was in each sample and we
ran them with our pcr assay and
determine the threshold cycle-free
choosing the same volume and when when
after we ran the reactions they sent us
the results we compared them you can see
that there's a beautiful correlation
between the threshold cycle that we
measured and the number of targets in
the sample as determined by digital PCR
so how does this work why does this work
that one of the key things is that be
the foot hybrid of the mutant target is
going to be seven long let's say and the
foot the foot hybrid with the wild-type
will be perhaps five nucleotides long
less strong so we we did thermodynamic
calculations to see if this could
account for this 20 cycle difference in
the appearance of the ambler amplicons
and that's a millionfold difference and
the answer is thermodynamics does
not account for such a big difference
something else is going on and this is
why I put emphasis on on the nature of
the foot hybrid itself because stronger
hybrids like the egfr l 8580 made it a
little harder to discriminate then weak
weak or hybrids such as the original be
roughly 600 e which were 80 rich so the
nature of that foot hybrid is also
affecting the outcome and we we now
believe we understand this it turns out
that the anchor hybrid twenty four
nucleotides long is is so strong that it
persists throughout the once forms it
persists throughout the whole annealing
stage of the PCR 20 seconds it probably
exists for a persist for a minute or so
but these little bitty hybrids exists
for less the foot hybrids exist for less
than one second maybe only a few hundred
milliseconds and it turns out that the
mismatched hybrids the hybrid of the
foot with the wild-type that is so short
it only exists for a few milliseconds so
there's a big difference in the
persistence time of these hybrids I mean
it's at equilibrium they're falling
apart going back together but basically
when the hybrid is formed it has to
encounter a DNA polymerase and and get
the formation of the amplicon started
and the seven long full fully
complementary hybrids with the mutant
they're able to in pretty much encounter
a DNA polymerase but the mismatched
hybrids of the wild-type are so short
and less for such a little time they
don't have time to encounter a DNA
polymerase they fall apart before that
so I let me sort of summarize this in
the past people have tried to get highly
selective essays by making a good strong
mute
hybrid primer that makes a strong hybrid
and make a weaker a much less strong
mismatch hybrid with the wild type that
worked but not great what we've done is
we've made both the perfectly matched
hybrid and the mismatched hybrid very
very weak but because we've made them
both weak the mismatched wild-type
hybrid is so you could hardly exists in
it falls apart so there's this second
factor by making everything week and
that is that they the mismatch ones
don't even last long enough to get a DNA
polymerase and so the combination of
thermodynamics and this difference in
the short lives of the foot hybrids that
accounts for the incredible selectivity
of our heart primers however just all of
these things I've shown you our
mono-plex assay is looking for just one
mutation practical assays that are going
to look at liquid biopsy samples need to
look at multiple mutations not only that
many of these mutations although they
occur in different cells will occur in
the same be located in the same or
adjacent codons that's the case for the
K rass mutations and the b-raf mutation
and the egfr mutations all of which are
relevant to cancer diagnosis prognosis
and therapy so we need to have a
multiplex essay and we need to have a
multiplex assay that overcomes the
problem that there will be different
different amplicons that are virtually
identical to each other so here on the
slide we're showing the five problems
that need to be overcome but we were
using cyber green for the mono-plex
assays but in multiplex SI you need to
use differently colored probes that can
light up each of the different amplicons
that would be generated if that means
mutant target is present ah ordinarily
if if one had jeans and totally
different chromosomes there'd be no
problem
finding a probe that could uniquely bind
to each of the different amplicons but
since these amplicons are virtually
identical to each other the same anchor
sequences virtually the same rest of the
amplicon you can't use a fluorescent
probe that goes into the middle of the
amplicons that has to be solved the
other thing is with primers sharing the
same anchor sequence save for the K
wrasse mutations how you make sure that
only the right primer out of the set of
primers that go to the same gene will go
on in amplicon if an amplicon has one
particular mutants out of four and there
are four different primers you've got to
make sure that the only the correct
primer goes that amplicon that's problem
number 23 if they're two mutants are
present that occur in the same gene nerd
civic same code on if one is more
abundant than the other you know that
during an amplification you keep on
making plus and minus strands until
finally there are so many that they
start to form double strands that's why
PCR reactions go from being exponential
to quasi-linear because it's hard for
the primers to get in there into the
double strands goes quasi-linear but if
you have now a combination of amplicons
one from an abundant mutant and another
from a much rarer mutant once the
amplicons from the more abundant mutants
start to form double strands the less
abundant mutant will get caught up as
hetero duplexes in those double strands
and they will not be able to undergo
continued exponential amplification that
has to be solved and finally we've seen
that each different target having a
different sequence has a different
propensity to get initiated so the the
threshold values vary so we have to have
some way to fine-tune all of the primers
that are put into a multiplex reaction
so that the same the same threat of
threshold cycle from any of those
primers will represent the same number
of targets in the original sample
and the last problem is that we don't
want to have to determine the amount of
DNA that we put into a sampling in fact
if you take a plasma sample a blood
sample from the same patient a few hours
apart you take a number of samples
you'll find that there are different
amounts of DNA fragments in each sample
it varies quite a bit from hour to hour
so we want to add into our multiplex
reactions the amplification of a
reference gene whose threshold cycle
will tell you how much DNA is in there
and you'll see that that's very
important so let me quickly go through
the various things that we've done first
in order to detect the different
amplicons we using molecular beacons
which is a fluorescent probe developed
in our laboratory you can see from the
picture that their little hairpin shaped
probes where the probe sequence the part
that matches the target is complementary
to the target is in the loop of the
hairpin and that probe sequence is
embedded within two arm sequences that
are unrelated to the target sequence but
they're complementary to each other so
they form this little hairpin stem and
on either end of that probe is a floor
for Ana quencher and and the molecular
beacon floating around in solution is
completely dark it's not fluorescent and
the reason is that fluorophores do not
have side groups that wiggle-waggle or
rotate so that if they are stimulated if
they absorb energy from light ah they
don't have side groups that can dispense
disperse that energy through the motion
of side groups as heat so instead they
fluoresce but the quencher molecules
that we use do have side groups that
wiggle-waggle and rotate and when the
quencher and the floor for are close to
each other bonds are formed between them
hydrogen bonds PI bonds whatever and so
when the fluorophore in the floating
around molecular beacon absorbs energy
from stimulating light it passes across
those bonds to the
quencher whose side groups release that
energy as heat and there is no
fluorescence it's only when the
molecular beacon binds to its target
that the rigidity of the probe target
hybrid forces those arms apart then
breaking the bonds between the floor for
in the quencher and then when the floor
for is absorbed energy they only can
release it as present light of a pre
chosen color and you can use a variety
of different colored floor forest in
multiplex SI using a variety of
different molecular beacons so here's
what we did I think I will get the
little marker here uh let me see ah yes
so in addition to the anchor sequence
and the bridge sequence and the foot
sequence we add to each super selective
primer a five-prime tag sequence and
this isn't going to affect the
selectivity or initiation of synthesis
and you can see that once the amplicon
begins to be made you have normal
exponential amplification producing both
plus and minus strands and the minus
strands contain a complement of the five
prime tag sequence of the primer however
we also when we set up these reactions
reduce the concentration of the super
selective primer compared to the
concentration of the common reverse
primer so we might have 16 animal or
super selective primer but five hundred
or a thousand animal or of reverse
primer so what happens is exponential
amplification runs out when all the
super selective primers for that target
are used up but the reverse primer which
is more abundant keeps on making
products so you get an excess of minus
strands and that's shown in the lower
diagram and we have in the reaction a
molecular beacon whose probe sequence is
complementary to the complement of the
five prime tag sequence on the primer so
the result is that once exponential
amplification has run out you get a
linear
synthesis of minus amplicons which are
lit up biomolecular beacon whose probe
is complementary to that five prime tag
and in multiplex assays we're going to
use different super selective primers
each containing a different tank
sequence and we're going to have
different molecular beacons each
containing a differently colored floor
42 and each of them only binds to their
own tag sequence ah here's an example
just of a mono-plex reaction for the
egfr g 7 19 s mutation using a molecular
beacon we used 40,000 wild-type
fragments and different numbers of
mutant fragments going to as little as
four mutant fragments and you see what
beautiful results you get using a
molecular beacon to light up the
amplicons now here's an example of
multiplex a duplex a reaction so you see
there are two different molecular
beacons they are one for the five prime
tag sequence of a v600 are super
selective primer and the other one the
red one for a complimentary to the or
not complimentary actually the probe
sequence is identical the five prime
tech sequence the probe sequence in the
beacon will be complementary to the
compliment to the five contacts sequence
now there's one other aspect that we
have to worry about when you have two or
more different primers for virtually the
same gene you have this how are you
going to assure that only the correct
primer binds to the amplicon so here let
me use this little pointer again this
whole bottom strand here that's a minus
strand to which super selective primer
has to bind now it's quite possible that
an incorrect primer which shares the
same anchor sequence as the correct
primer a will in fact bind to the minus
strand even a molecular beacon could
bind but because each super selective
primer has its own unique bridge
sequence
chosen by us only the correct primer
will bind to the complement of that
bridge sequence that's in the amplicon
so this assures that no matter what
happens each amplicon is only copied by
its own correct primer another problem
that occurs in in this case we we
purposely ran reactions in which in
addition to 10,000 wild-type b-raf
wild-type templates we we put in every
reaction a thousand copies of beer at
v600e mutants but in each reaction we
put in different numbers of B of v600
our mutation and what we realized is
that the v600 es will all sort of reach
the threshold cycle somewheres around 35
cycles here but you'll notice that the B
the B rafi 600 years instead of having
having separate threshold cycles they
get caught up in a heteroduplex with the
v600e and so you can't really get proper
threshold cycles for v600 are this
demonstration was done using equal
concentrations of the super selective
primer and the reverse primer however
when we go to using only 16 ana molars
of each super selective primer and
having much more of the reverse primer
then you don't have the heteroduplex
problem there's less Plus strands of the
more abundant primer to get tangled up
with the rare minus strands of the v600
our primer and you get a beautiful
separation look on the left of the v600
our primer and there's something else
that helps here is a picture that shows
the a red amplicon from a plus strand
from a mutation who's super sexy primer
has been used up and it's bound to a a
minus strand of a very rare mutation
that is still undergoing exponential
amplification and what you can see is
that it's not a perfect duplex in fact
the
and I'll use the pointer again the
bridge sequence of the plus strand of
the more abundant amplicon is not
complementary to the complement of the
different bridge sequence of the less
abundant amplicon as a result you get a
unaccessible bubble and it's right here
in this minus strand a complement to the
bridge sequence that the super selective
primer for that rarer target can get in
there bind and generate amplicons and
that's why the heteroduplex problem is
solved further since we know that
different target sequences having
different GC contents what have you
different sequences are have a
differential efficiency we and you can
see that in the left-hand panel or is a
duplex reaction run with Abby v600 Arnav
v600e primer and everything is the same
in terms of quantities but the threshold
values of the the red one which is the
v600e came later v600e is very 80 rich
and the threshold cycles came later so
we are able to fine-tune the situation
by altering the size and even somewhat
the sequence of the bridge sequence
that's in the super selective primer for
v600e so you see this one that didn't
work so well in left-hand panel it had a
15 / 9 bridge sequence and it the
threshold cycles came too late but then
when we redid exactly the same
experiment using a brf v600e super
selective primer with a 10-9 the shorter
the circumference a shorter by five
nucleotides this made the entropy
they're getting back together of the
foot and a foot target hybrid more
probable and then the very
same threshold cycles on the Left
indicate the very same number of target
molecules on the x-axis in the right
hand diagram so we're able to fine-tune
all of the super selective primers that
we put in because our super selective
primers have a unique sequence chosen by
us whose identity and size we can bury
now the last thing is we wanted to have
a reference gene also made now the
referent here's a trip Lex reaction the
reference gene happens to be a cancer
target that we have around but we're
using the wild type so it could be made
actin it could be anything but we happen
to you as the bottom super selective
primer is for egfr wild-type and you see
there are three different super
selective primers there are reverse
primers a separate reverse primer for
the egfr and a common reverse primer for
the brf three different molecular
beacons each labeled in with different
colored fluorophores and other than that
the super selective primer concentration
is low and the reverse primers are high
it's a quite ordinary pcr we're looking
at the fluorescence at the end of
annealing stage and we looking with at
the fluorescence from three different
colors so i want to show you how this
works so there's to react to experiments
here i'm going to show the results of so
in these reactions first of all every
every single reaction contained 10,000
b-raf wild types but there's no there's
no primer for the wild type they also
are contained 10,000 egfr while types
which are going to be that a reference
gene target and then in the experiment
shown on this screen in every tube there
are a thousand of b-raf be 600 e targets
but different numbers of v600 our
targets and what i want to show you i'll
use the marker again
uh I think this is it yeah so here we're
in the red you can see that the CT value
of the wild-type reference gene is the
same for all reactions the CT value
looked at in a different color
fluorescence is the v600 es they have a
common CT value for the thousand targets
but the CT values for the v600 ours vary
depending upon how many were in there
all the way down in 10 if you take these
results in the lower right hand corner
and plot them you find that all of the
CT values of these six hundred are lie
on a straight line the CT value for the
pure v6 of wild-type ah that is when if
we look at the the fluorescence that we
get for the molecular beacon for v600
are when there are no targets in there
the CT value is is up here it's this 55
or so and all of the ones that contain
mutations right down to 10 lie on this
straight straight line but here's the
other thing because we fine-tuned
everything all thousand v600 ease come
give you the same CT value and all of
the reference genes give you the same CT
value why does this mean well before I
tell you what this means here's the
reverse experiment everything's the same
except this time we used 1000 v600 our
targets in every tube and different
numbers of v600e targets and again when
you plot it everything goes on the
straight line now this tells you that
you can do multiplex reactions using a
different super selective primer for
each target the number of probes you
primers you put in depends upon the
number of colors you can discern if you
don't care whether three or four
mutations which ones they are but you
only want to see if any one of them
occur you can put in for super selective
primers all with the same five prime tag
sequence that are lit up by the same
molecular beacon and if you
at a signal from any of those that will
be satisfactory but again because you
have a threshold cycle value for a
reference wild-type that tells you how
much DNA is in there and it's sir the
fact that you get amplification tells
you that everything's working well the
PCR is going and where the threshold
value comes up for the reference gene
that tells you how much DNA you have and
if if that threshold cycle comes up too
late it means you don't have enough DNA
to look for the rare targets that that
sample is not satisfactory but if it
comes up early as will generally be the
case all you have to do is compare the
threshold cycle or the reference gene to
the threshold cycle of the mutant that
you're going to detect if it's there to
give you a measure of the abundance of
that mutation and that's clinically what
matters so I would say I really have a
conclusion here that if you use fine
tune super selective primers possessing
primer specific sequences for detection
and for target selectivity you combine
that with non symmetric primer
concentrations in the use of an internal
reference gene target and this enables
the routine use of PCR reactions to
detect and quantitate rare mutations
that occur in the same or adjacent
codons in the presence of abundant
wild-type sequences this means that this
approach low-cost simple assays done
with with blood samples that are easily
taken frequently can be used routinely
to manage the care of individual
patients that's the promise of this okay
i just want to show you my colleagues
here's Salvatore Maris he's been in a
lab I don't know 15 20 years something
like 20 I think and he is from the
Netherlands here is Deanna Vargas she's
from the country of Colombia she's been
in the lab 15 years all these
experiments were actually carried out by
Deanna and here's my long term
laboratory colleague sanjiang Tyagi's
from India we've shared a lab
for 29 years and if you would like to
hear more about this approach if you
would like to try it out if you'd like
to collaborate with us please contact me
at the following we have a email address
and we'll get in touch with you and see
what we can do and that's basically my
talk and I was wondering if there are
any questions
I'm sorry I believe no Boyd didn't have
any audio for a minute dr. Kramer thank
you so much for that great presentation
now before we get started on the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit the questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green here
innate button at the lower left of the
presentation window we all try to get um
try to answer as many questions as we
can okay dr. Kramer our first question
is what is the best way to use positive
control for lip liquid biopsy pcr what
what should I use amplicons plasmid or
cancer tissue DNA samples okay uh all
the work that we've done in our
laboratory has has been either with
plasmids or just DNA fragments or with
DNA isolated from tissue culture cells
as basically we're not clinicians and
we've done all of our work with model
templates I think now it's it's time for
actual clinical samples to be used so is
so if you're developing an asset you
could well do it the way that we did it
which is use artificial targets to get
everything fine tuned and and set up and
you're confident with it but then one
has to check it out using clinical
samples which we haven't done yet and
and then ultimately ah you're going to
make measurements on already previously
characterized clinical samples and I
don't know the source I'm not a
clinician but the thing that you'll
measure with the assays is the
difference between the threshold cycle
of the reference gene and the threshold
cycle of the mutation should it be there
and one would want to correlate that
difference where a smaller difference
means there's more mutations there with
the symptoms that are present or with
the previous measurements
are done by other methods I i should say
one other thing that is that you might
use a low-cost simple or rapid pcr SI to
search for mutations if you find
something positive clinically it might
be then appropriate to do a more
elaborate much more expensive next-gen
sequencing to look at multiple mutations
that are relevant to the situation but I
mean what we're looking here is to get
something that could be used routinely
frequently for people who don't have
cancer and for people of cancer to get
to the problems that occur much much
earlier and therefore it's much easier
to treat the patient with better
outcomes III think that's the best that
I can do okay so you can regain control
nice question dr. Payman does your PCR
primers design give advantages for
digital droplet pcr am I on now dot look
that's a very very good question uh it
it does in the following sense these
mutations are so rare and especially if
you want to look for multiplexes that
you'd have to do millions and millions
of droplets and digital digital PCR
millions and millions of wells because
you have to distinguish your your
product that gets made it's all or none
its endpoint in digital PCR from
wild-type but if you use super selective
primers let's say in every droplet you
have one or no mutant target initially
and then that's amplified but you might
have one or two hundred wild-type
targets because there's so much more
abundant in that droplet but if you use
super selective primers those wild types
will easily
uh the repressed they won't make
amplicons so the answer there is yes
super sucker primers will help in
digital PCR there's something else and
that is I've talked about molecular
beacons of using say five or six or
maybe as many as 10 depending upon the
instrument that you use in PCR but our
lab has actually worked on ways to label
molecular beacons with three different
colors out of say seven and there are 35
different ways to choose three colors
out of seven and each a molecular beacon
for each of 35 different targets can be
labeled with a unique set of three
colors it's not done by putting three
floors on one molecular beacon molecule
it's by taking one molecular beacon
molecule without a floor for but with a
quencher divided into three test tubes
and then in one test tubes say put in a
green floor for another test tube add on
a red floor for and third test tube at
once' a yellow floor for then mix them
all together you now have one molecular
beacon with one probe sequence but a
third of them read a third of them
agreeing a third Nomar yellow so you
could have 35 different unique molecular
beacons for unique tag sequences and
even though you only distinguish seven
colors in which there's only going to be
three for any droplet unless there's a
rare chance that two targets have
occurred in the same droplet you can do
highly multiplex digital PCR but this
requires a PCR machine that can discern
say seven different colors in each
droplet or can take a spectrum and then
dissociate it mathematically into the
contribution of each of seven colors
these don't another alternative is to
use beaming where the amplicon products
and their probes are attached to little
particles those particles are sent
through a flow cytometer and the flow
cytometers can take a spectrum of each
particle and dissociate them so yeah
there are a lot of possibilities to
combine this with digital PCR but I'm
still an advocate of low-cost the 2250
dollars depending upon who knows market
conditions to run an essay with regular
ordinary pcr on this there must be a
hundred thousand spectral fluorometric
thermal cyclers spread throughout the
world already and assays could be made
for anyone okay I think that's the
answer to this thank you dr. Kramer your
great questions coming in when your time
for one more question our audience
member says interesting talk dr. Kramer
for the last slide you showed I would
like to confirm the CT values from my
previous work anything more than 40
seats CTS is considered loads less than
48 stock using less than 40 cc's is
considered low sample please clarify why
your graph starts to rise starting at 40
I understand that you set the cycles up
to 60 what is the state of your sample
way I don't think I fully on your skin I
don't think I fully understand the
question ah beat because we're using
super selective primers whose foot
target foot foot and foot target hybrid
is very small the probability of
initiating synthesis is nowhere as near
a hundred percent it's a little low
probability that makes the threshold
cycles come out later however once an
amplicon is generated then it's
exponentially amplified and of course
there are multiple targets in there so
they're multiplying and and that means
they're multiple chances to get started
also in each subsequent thermal cycle
the reverse primers copy the plus
strands making more minus strands so it
is a linear increase in the number of
target strands for the super selective
primers as the super as the reaction
occurs the PCR reaction occurs so
find that it's highly reproducible that
the threshold cycle that you get even
though it's later than a conventional
pcr for the same number of targets it
reliably reflects the number of targets
that were in the sample that's why you
get these beautiful plots of the
threshold cycle being inversely related
to the log of the number of targets that
were in the sample and not only that
I'll say this that we wouldn't have time
to go into it that we're working on ways
to assure that even if there's only one
or two target molecules in a sample that
you will get a reliable signal almost
all the time saying that something is
there you won't get false negatives and
you won't get false positives and that
is the kind of extreme sensitivity that
you need for the wide adoption of these
pcr approaches to detecting somatic
mutations relevant to cancer all right I
don't know if that answers your question
but hopefully it will help a bit thank
you again dr. Fred cream